people of the internet hello and welcome
to the retro raconteur show tonight we
are going to review Netflix's new show
The Witcher we're gonna take your
questions right here on twitch.tv slash
retro rack and tour if you're watching
this on youtube later know that you also
can watch this live every Monday
Wednesday Friday again at twitch.tv
slash retro rack and tour those of you
here now watching live you can hit that
follow button in the top right corner to
make sure that you always stay
up-to-date on the streams you can also
follow me over on twitter at retro rack
and tour and on instagram at retro rack
and tour as well so what do I have to
say about it it's interesting you know I
have I should probably first tell you my
exposure to The Witcher as a franchise
before this show and it's only the game
it's only the game The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt is literally my only exposure to
this franchise I never played the first
Witcher I never played The Witcher 2 I
haven't read any of the books all eight
in one day instead say no no we didn't
watch all eight in one day so that's the
perspective that I brought in the show
as soon as I heard they announced it I
was like I gotta watch this gotta watch
this I'm a big fantasy fan in general
and the first thing I saw was that they
cast Henry Cavill as as Geralt and then
I saw that first image of him so I was a
little bit concerned about Henry Cavill
overall though overall I thought he was
absolutely incredible perfectly embodied
Geralt that I had in my mind he does the
video game voice almost exactly like the
video game guy I thought he absolutely
nailed it I mean he really and even the
author of the books has since came out
and talked about how much he was pleased
and then I've learned all this
additional stuff about Henry Cavill host
this show coming out
apparently is a big-time gamer he's a
big gamer he loves The Witcher he he
he's into
see gaming not console PC but uh but
yeah he's real into the series and so it
shows man it shows in his acting he did
it he did a fantastic job with it but
overall I would say that I enjoyed it
obviously I finished it all the way
through pretty fast I enjoyed it but but
there's a there's a very big butt in
there and that's because this show to me
at least has some some major major flaws
I thought there were there were some big
flaws in there Rick mostly regarding the
way they decided to tell the story and
kind of the pace of the story there
there's a lot of jumping around there's
a lot of jumping to different characters
characters are introduced very very
quickly in this I mean like I said it's
only eight episodes they're hour long
each
but characters come and go I mean super
super fast it's like one scene you're
like wait who is this and then by the
time you you figure out like you're
starting to understand who this person
is they're gone and then like two
episodes later oh there's that person
again or they talk about that person
again and you're like wait which one was
that the action is fantastic throughout
the the swordplay in particular I
thought they did a really really good
job with so I love I love Cabell as
Geralt
I love the swordplay and the action sort
of everything holding it together though
I thought I thought struggled a little
bit you've heard some book readers
expressed disappointment as well well I
I had been kind of popping into the The
Witcher subreddit they've got like the
little episode by episode threads over
there Christian and I would I would sort
of read a little bit about what they had
to say after each episode and a lot of
the folks over there are the book fans
and so I was I was picking up on a
little bit of that too but they were
also explaining things that I didn't
pick up by watching the show and then
after they explained I'm like oh that
actually if they had done a better
job of developing this plot in the show
we're not talking spoilers yet but if
they had done a better job developing
this that would have hit home a lot more
for me whereas somebody who was only
sort of casually interested in The
Witcher just played the game yeah I was
I was pretty lost so on that subreddit
they actually explained a lot of it so
overall I really I did enjoy the show
despite having some major major problems
with it it kind of gave off this uh
Kevin Sorbo Hercules vibe a little bit
but I just I kept getting a little bit
of that vibe that they were trying to
tell these little contain stories but
they were having to go so fast that even
within the little contained story it
didn't really give the characters enough
time to develop there so there there are
three main characters that this this
eight initial episodes oh dude I loved
Hercules - man I mean I watched I
watched Hercules all the time but I
haven't seen in a long time I feel like
if we went back now we would just be
like oh man this is a little the sets I
thought were great the costumes were
really good for the most part the the
music
I thought fit perfectly with the with
the franchise Christiano with the resub
they're just going to you which I
thought uh jasker I think is how it's
pronounced in the show who is dandelion
in the books I thought he was great when
you first meet him it's kind of like I
don't know about this guy and then by
the end you're like okay I like this
dude a lot
the songs are catchy I didn't feel I'm
just gonna sound ridiculous because I
finished all eight in a week but uh with
a lot of these Netflix shows I mean we
talked about binge Watchers you just get
so into it that you have to hit that
next episode next episode I never really
felt that and I don't know if it's
because they want wanted to base each
one on a contained story so it has like
a nice little into it after each episode
but not until the very
did I feel like oh I really want to see
what happens so I would get to the end
of an episode and just be like okay you
know I can walk away I was I was told a
story it's a little confusing I was told
this story now that tiny little story is
is done in 10 Sam yeah this is not a
binge watching series yeah and so it's
like and I don't know if it's a bad
thing
but it's I don't know if it's a good
thing because I feel like those shows
that I really get attached to her those
ones where you just like yes dude I want
to see what happens next please next
episode next episode next this with no
exposure to the game no exposure to the
books if somebody watched this I don't
know that they would continue they may
watch one two episodes but then I don't
know if they're gonna continue on and it
kind of goes back to that last point
about the binge watching nature like I
don't know that they would feel
compelled to go on because nothing
nothing's really left on a cliffhanger
there's not really any big mysteries
introduced early on it's just kind of
here's what's happening so I think that
I think at least from that part of it it
is a little bit of a negative because I
don't know that they're gonna be able to
bring in a lot of because I feel like
fantasy fans in general would flock to
this would flock to this and would would
really love it okay we got a question
here from Minton Sam do you think season
one was just an intro to all of the
characters of the series and going
forward they'll continue a linear story
I do think that that's kind of what I'm
thinking I haven't read a lot of
interviews yet but I think there was one
comment from from cavil that sort of is
leading people to believe that it's
going to tell a much tighter story from
here on I definitely think you're
spot-on that it's an intro to the
characters there are some really
interesting characters in this in this
world and the world is great
I mean it's based on a book a very
successful book series it's been made
into a video game clearly they already
have all the lore they could ever need
you know they have all of this stuff
that they could
from so it's got to be interesting to
see but I I definitely think it will
only get better and I will say this as
well I felt like um and Christian might
agree and he kind of alluded to this a
little bit already the story does get
better as you go on as some of the plot
lines start to converge together as some
of the characters start to some of the
guy I don't want to give away too much
but as some of the characters start to
interact more with one another let's
just say that they the story does get a
little much easier to follow and as a
result I felt like I became more
invested in it as it got towards the end
like five from episode like five I think
all the way through the finish had eight
the story is much better it's not
straight linear but it is it is a little
bit easier to follow at that point but
that's gonna be it for now guys thank
you all so much I will talk to you again
very soon thank you for being here
tonight have a good one guys